.
>> Tucker: WELL, SPEAKING OF
LYING, IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT IN
FRONT OF US.
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN A MONTH
SINCE PAUL PELOSI WAS ATTACKED
IN HIS HOME ON A FRIDAY NIGHT IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE ASSAILANT, A HIPPIE NUDIST,
A RIGHT WING EXTREMIST, DESPITE
BEING A BLACK MATTER LIVES FAN.
PAUL PELOSI DIDN'T SEEM AFRAID
OF DEPAPE.
IN FACT HE OPENED THE DOOR FOR
THE COPS HIMSELF.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PELOSI
HOUSE THAT NIGHT?
A LOT OF CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT IT, AND PEOPLE WHO PUT
THOSE FORWARD HAVE BEEN ATTACKED
FOR IT.
YOU'RE CRAZY.
SO THERE'S ONE WAY TO END THIS
DEBATE IMMEDIATELY.
IT WOULD BE A CONSTITUTIONAL WAY
TO END IT.
IN FACT, WE SHOULD BE DEMANDING
IT.
THAT'S TO SEE THE BODY CAM
FOOTAGE FROM THAT NIGHT, BECAUSE
THESE POLICE ARE PUBLIC
SERVANTS, WORK FOR THE REST OF
US, AND HAVE NO RIGHT TO HIDE
THAT.
BUT THE POLICE, FOR SOME REASON,
HAVE REFUSED TO RELEASE THAT
BODY CAM FOOTAGE.
WE GET BODY CAM FOOTAGE EVERY
DAY IN THE NEWS BUSINESS.
THEY'RE INTENT ON NOT RELEASING
IT.
IN DEPAPE'S FEDERAL COURT CASE,
A JUDGE ISSUED A BAN FROM
RELEASING IT.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
WHY ARE THEY HIDING THIS?
IS THERE A GOOD REASON?
WE DON'T KNOW.
LARRY ELDER RAN FOR GOVERNOR IN
CALIFORNIA, A STATE IN WHICH
HE'S LIVED FOR MANY YEARS.
HE JOINS US TO ASSESS WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE.
LARRY, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHY CAN'T WE END THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE EVIDENCE
THAT WE HAVE A RIGHT TO SEE?
>> OF COURSE, WE'RE SPECULATING,
BUT SOMEBODY DOES NOT WANT
SOMEBODY TO KNOW WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED THAT DAY.
I DON'T KNOW.
THE NBC REPORTER, WHO REPORTED
THAT PELOSI CALMLY OPENED THE
DOOR, SAID HE HAD A HAMMER IN
HIS HAND, AND CALMLY WALKED
BACK.
THAT GUY GOT SUSPENDED.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY FOOTAGE, ANY
AUDIO.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE WITNESSES
ARE SAYING.
MAYBE PAUL PELOSI KNEW THE GUY.
MAYBE NANCY PELOSI KNEW THE GUY.
MAYBE PAUL INVITED HIM IN.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT THE OFFICIAL
STORY THAT WE'VE HEARD, WHICH IS
VERY SIMPLE, THIS GUY BROKE INTO
PAUL PELOSI'S HOUSE AND ATTACKED
HIM DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE THE
CASE.
OTHERWISE WHY SO SECRETIVE?
WHY NOT TELL WHAT'S GOING ON?
WHY THE GAG ORDER?
I'VE NEVER SEEN.
>> Tucker: I'VE MET PAUL PELOSI,
AND HE'S A VERY NICE MAN.
I WOULDN'T BE DOING THE STORY
RIGHT NOW IF THEY HADN'T USED IT
TO ATTACK THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS?
THEY USED THIS STORY TO ATTACK
THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
WE HAVE AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT AND
OBLIGATION TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I SAID SOMETHING SNARKY ABOUT IT
AFTER I MADE SURE THAT PAUL
PELOSI WAS GOING TO RECOVER
FULLY, AND I WAS ATTACKED, AND
OTHER CONSERVATIVES ATTACKED.
YOU'RE QUITE RIGHT, WE OUGHT TO
KNOW WHAT THE STORY IS.
IT WAS USED TO SHOW HOW
INSENSITIVE AND CALLOUS
CONSERVATIVES ARE BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS.
>> Tucker: THEY'LL USE ANYTHING,
EVEN HER HUSBAND'S ATTACK, AS
YOU WELL KNOW, HAVING BEEN
ATTACKED.
>> I'M THE BLACK FACE